and I am so excited to talk about escape
from New York it's all my favorite
movies from the 80s lockout what's that
it's called lock out you idiot oh I
thought Kurt Russell look weird lock out
stars guy Pierce and Maggie grace it's a
lupus on production you know him from
movies like the professional favela men
are taken and this movie guy Pierce is
framed for a crime he didn't commit
and he's given two options he can go to
jail for 30 years or he can be sent to
this Space Station which is a prison
where the prisoners have broken out and
the president's daughter is trapped
there and he has to go there and rescue
her guy Pierce is an actor I really like
he's very underrated and he's a really
good addition this movie in fact he is
honestly the best part of this movie to
be honest because this movie ain't that
great unfortunately as an actor I think
he has loads of town he just exudes
charm in this movie I mean his character
is very entertaining he's the kind of
guy that you saw him on the street it'd
be like this hey man I like your shirt
what are you looking at Punk it's like
that and I like that about him he
reminded me a little bit of John McClane
a little bit of Snake Plissken a little
bit of all different types of movie hero
they know it's fun when you got a cool
guy who's got a lot of charm and he's
good at telling jokes and he's in this
situation where you think the average
person will be peeing their pants but
he's joking about it it's fun
besides Guy Pearce though that's what we
kind of fell apart for me it is fun from
time to time it is I had some fun with
this movie but for the most part the
story is so weak and everything is so
cliched it seems so much like it's
copying on other science fiction films
as well Maggie Grace is in this movie
she plays the president's daughter you
know her from movies like taken she
played Liam Neeson's daughter he had to
rescue her in that and that was also a
lupus on production interesting I
actually just made that connection in my
head you learned things doing these
reviews and she was fine I mean I don't
know it didn't seem like there was
really much chemistry between her and
Guy Pearce and I really think a lot of
that is the filmmakers fault if this
movie seems weakly directed it also
seems very under budget for what they
were trying to portray some special
effects look really good in space some
of the scenes that look great but
however some look awful there is a
motorcycle chase scene in the early part
of the movie that looked horrendous it
looked like the cutscene and a Nintendo
GameCube game you could tell that human
actions were like sped up really fast
to somehow try to mesh with the
computer-generated imagery behind it it
was awful
terrible scene see something that's
really important with a movie like this
with an action movie or a science
fiction movie of this type you need a
good villain this movie does not have a
good villain they're basically two main
villains in this movie there's this one
really insane guy who just like has
seizures all the time and kills people
terrible villain then there's another
guy who is more calm he was more of the
brains of the operation he also was very
undeveloped it was just nothing there it
was just this terrible writing
uninteresting villainous characters now
I'm saying bad things about it but this
movie was not terrible though I wouldn't
say it's one of the worst movies I've
seen all year it just is a very mediocre
just run-of-the-mill kind of film I had
some entertainment from the scenes it
wasn't a boring movie I was never bored
by the movie I loved Guy Pearce in it I
think he's a very underrated actor I'd
love to see him do more things I would
say if you can catch it on cable or
maybe if your friend rents it and you
don't have to pay for it you still might
not enjoy it but that might be a little
better than paying full price so because
I was mildly entertained by the film but
for the most part it was just mad mad I
gave lock-out a C I just really you guys
know I've got a lot of requests to
review the movie the raid I will be
seeing it tomorrow it finally came out
in Ohio
everyone's been asked me like dude why
are you reviewing the raid because I
haven't had a chance to see it until
tomorrow and I will see it tomorrow and
I'll have my review up then and until
then you can subscribe to my channel and
get stuck mine eyes